or sewage treatment plants, or nuclear reactors.
All of these major pieces of expensive hardware
are run by what are called industrial control systems.
And this module, we're going to talk about industrial control systems
and internet of things.
Let's start with industrial control systems.
In this module, we're going to talk about industrial control systems
and internet of things.
Let's start with industrial control systems.
And a definition, what are industrial control systems?
Well, industrial control systems are the hardware and the software
that control big expensive hardware.
So think manufacturing facilities with all those raw watts
that are building cars or iPhones.
Or think of water treatment plants, or sewage treatment plants,
or nuclear reactors.
All of these major pieces of expensive hardware
are run by what are called industrial control systems.
So given that these industrial control systems control very expensive
and often very delicate and potentially catastrophic systems
if they were to fail, like nuclear power plants or water treatment plants,
these systems have to be very secure and very reliable.
There's three major types of industrial control systems
that you need to know both for the examine.
You do not have to be an expert on these,
but you should recognize that these systems,
you're the names of these systems,
are examples of industrial control systems.
The most common are SCADA systems.
You've also got DCS and PLC systems.
And actually remember for the exam,
you do not have to memorize all these acronyms.
There'll be a little window that you can button that you can click
that will show you a pop-up window that contains all sorts of acronyms
and what they actually stand for.
So you don't have to memorize the exact wording of these things
and you won't get definitional type questions on that.
So be aware SCADA, DCS and PLC.
These are very common types of industrial control systems.
Now, the big risk that we have with industrial control systems
is that these are very expensive,
very important systems that are controlling,
often extremely expensive, very delicate systems.
And the big security risk is that the hardware,
the software that these SCADA systems are running around
or these industrial control systems are running on
is often very outdated.
It's not uncommon to come across industrial control systems
that are still running on like Windows NT.
It's crazy sometimes.
So let's start with a question.
Why are some of these such critical systems running
on such old antiquated hardware and software?
And the answer is these are very, very critical systems
that are often highly customized.
So it's often very difficult to upgrade
the underlying operating system and hardware.
And a lot of these big facilities very much run by the philosophy
of if it ain't broken, don't fix it.
Because you do not want to cause an outage
or cause these systems to malfunction.
So in many cases, we have very outdated,
very insecure hardware and underlying operating systems
that these industrial control systems are running on top of.
And yet these are extremely critical systems.
So how do we protect them?
How do we reduce the risk related to these systems?
The number one best way, and this is what you should remember
is the exam, air gap.
So air gaping is the concept that the industrial control system,
the network that it's on,
should absolutely not be connected to the rest
of the corporate network and especially the internet.
There should be a physical air gap,
literally no connection between the industrial control system
network and the rest of the corporate network
and especially the internet.
So remember air gaping is one of the best ways
of reducing the risk of industrial control systems.
Now, let's talk about the internet of things.
What is the internet of things?
Well, it's all sorts of devices
that have been given the ability to connect to the internet
that probably shouldn't be connected to the internet,
like your fridge and your stove and your dishwasher
and your light bulb.
So here's what's really led to this.
The ability to make a little computer chip,
basically a little mini computer
that has Wi-Fi capabilities and can connect to the internet
has become unbelievably cheap.
We can make these things for a couple of bucks.
And as a result, it's become extraordinarily cheap
to put these capabilities into all sorts of devices.
And that's exactly what's happening.
And there's a few big risks here.
One, most of these internet of things chips
are made by big OEM, original equipment manufacturers.
They were, there's just a few manufacturers
that make the vast majority of these
internet of things little computers
that enable this capability.
And security is not typically their top priority.
It's to make these things to the lowest possible dollar.
And so a lot of the internet of things devices out there
are wildly insecure.
They have big vulnerabilities in them.
And a lot of them are actually very difficult to patch.
And you combine that with the fact that
when you install these capabilities
in a lot of devices like a fridge or a stove,
I mean, who thinks to patch their fridge?
It's just, it's not something that people think about.
You plug this device in, you connect it to the internet,
and then you forget that it's there.
You forget it's connected to the internet.
And that leads to the next big risk.
And that is that these internet of things devices
can provide a really easy attack platform for a hacker.
So I'll give you an example of this.
The largest ever denial of service attack,
the largest ever denial of service attack in history,
originated from security cameras.
So someone discovered a vulnerability in security cameras,
installed some malware that allowed them
to remotely control these security cameras,
created a giant botnet essentially of these security cameras,
and then perpetrated the largest denial of service attack
in history from security cameras.
That's pretty ironic.
And that highlights the risk with these systems.
We don't realize they're connected to the internet,
and we don't think to patch them.
And because we've put them often deep inside of our corporate
networks or inside of our personal networks,
we don't think of the fact that someone
may be able to remotely connect to this device,
compromise the device, and now they're inside of our environment.
So how do we reduce the risk of internet of things devices?
How do we deal with this problem?
Well, it's best to think of internet of things devices
as a computer system, because that's literally what they are.
So all the same principles that you'd apply to protecting
any computer system apply to internet of things devices.
You need to make sure they're patched.
You need to make sure they're configured properly
that they have proper authentication in place.
And because it's often difficult to do all of that
with a lot of these devices,
network segmentation is really important.
Put these things on their own network segment.
If they truly do need to connect to the internet,
put them off in some network where that's
all that they can connect to, or even better yet,
don't connect them to any internet.
So that's internet of things.